okay foundational things
get more get sunlight in your eyes in
the morning especially on cloudy days as
many days of your life as you can and
make it a pleasureful thing yeah right
just get up and get outside get out on a
porch get outside you know take your
sunglasses just do it right
um uh most days if not every day
try and get your sleep right now younger
people with different schedules like
don't give up a social life but you know
try and get a good amount of sleep get
good at that some people are great
sleepers some people aren't
very good idea
if you want to be healthy to do three
days a week of weight training we're
talking about 10 minutes of warm up and
50 to 60 Minutes of working out if you
want we have a schedule like a that
encompasses all this that's on
hubermanlab.com you get it free there's
nothing to sell here it's just like a
fitness tool kit that we have a sleep
tool kit all that zero cost you just
downloads a PDF three pages so you don't
have to listen to me talk yeah then I
would say three days a week of
resistance training and train your legs
guys come on you know like how like come
on
um
and yeah and and
three days a week of some cardiovascular
work people might say well listen I'm in
my 20s or 30s like I'm not worried about
it it's not about being worried about a
heart attack it's about maintaining
blood flow to everything what is some
cardiovascular okay so I think one day a
week you take a long slow jog or pedal
on the bike or treadmill or Swim
whatever your favorite thing is if you
want to make it social and you're out
with somebody you could literally get
one like wear a weight vest for a hike
if you want to make it harder but um you
could skip rope whatever the other
cardio day
Sprint
is real easy find a patch of land Sprint
for 30 seconds to 45 seconds then walk
back for a minute to 90 seconds Sprint
again do that five to ten times till but
by the end you will have increased your
speed your VO2 max your output and then
another day make do something fun like
take I got a friend he's a musician I
won't name his name he's well known
musician he's like really into Pilates
right now probably for a bunch of
reasons loves Pilates he's like yo I'm
loving Pilates in these Pilates some
other cardiovascular thing that's kind
of fun it could be basketball yeah could
be skateboarding like something that you
enjoy at least three days a week the
other day is a weight train it's not
complicated and then one day a week just
take off as a recovery day and the way
to organize this so that your legs
recover in time for the Sprint day and
your Sprints are kind of double as a leg
day we have an episode on this called
toolkit for Fitness you don't have to
watch it you will just have our fitness
toolkit lays out the schedule exercise
selection rest sets all that super easy
it's minimal time commitment and listen
there are reasons to do it for aesthetic
reason is a reason to do it for heart
health reasons this is key okay so
sunlight that I think
have some tool to be able to control
your stress some people are super mellow
but some non-pharmaceutical tool the
double inhale through the nose the
physiological size so big deep inhale
through the nose then sneak in a little
bit more air then dump all your air with
your mouth that's the fastest way to
calm down
if you're scared of public speaking if
you uh you know you're tense about some
interaction and listen if I can't bring
you on board with that way um let's I'll
just be very direct you want to delay
orgasm
it works for that too because remember
orgasm is a increase in the Sim what we
call the sympathetic tone of the nervous
it's actually kind of like the stress
response and then comes the relaxation
afterwards so you know sort of like if
you need like a an incentive well and in
the tantric Community they talk about
using this type of breathing Tech to for
couples to be able to have sex for long
periods of time to be able to explore
the different forms of of sensual
connection so there you go like um
physiological jokes
well there is something called
retrograde you know about the retrograde
ejaculation thing right no well this is
crazy so the um and I have a story that
you have to be careful with this uh not
to get too wild with this so there is
this thing about
um there's a lot on the internet about
semen retention and Qi right yeah after
orgasm and here we're talking about
males and females but for in males after
ejaculation there's an increase in the
hormone prolactin which makes you very
mellow and that sets the refractory
period and during that time you're not
getting enough other actually you're not
having sex again this is why drugs that
increase dopamine
sometimes are are kind of pro-sexual
drugs but if people take too much of
them then they're just like all gas
pedal but they're not relaxed enough to
actually get an erection right this is
the cocaine thing right so you know sex
is a dance between arousal and
relaxation right Tantra under excuse me
understands that and they try and bring
people into kind of a mellow plane where
they are controlling all that that rise
and fall of of arousal over and over
again that's the idea
so there is this notion of ret in the
from in Asian certain Asian cultures
have talked about retaining Chi by
instead of allowing semen to leave the
body during orgasm they there's a
practice of pulling it back in by
inhaling and clamping essentially the
muscles around the prostate so I have a
friend who got really into experimenting
with this his wife um it happened to be
in the kind of Qigong Community uh was a
really interesting you know into Qigong
and he did this but he developed
terrible prostatitis so you have to be
really careful but he was walking around
feeling like he had twice as much energy
as he ever did before right before he's
about to bust he sucks it back in yeah
and again you can mess yourself up with
this you know that's crazy it's crazy
it's crazy it's like the worst idea it
seems like yeah exactly uh for some
people it's gonna be the worst idea for
other people you know you know I'm not
I'm not promoting this but there is this
notion of retrograde ejaculation do you
ever let it out do I personally yeah
do you like when you when you retrograde
do you ever actually ejaculate they do
they recommend they do it like you know
like once a week or something like that
I mean the yeah
um a lot as long as we're on this topic
if you do want to get your partner
pregnant
um stay out of hot tubs and saunas in
the 60 days preceding that oh 60 days
but you can put an ice pack between your
legs if you want to maintain you want to
keep your your testicles cool there's a
reason why the scrotum moves yeah yeah
because you keep the uh Concepts on us
yeah 60 days before trying to conceive
yeah and it's not a good form of birth
control either because I think plenty of
people have been conceived in hot tubs
and saunas yeah
um I don't know the exact number but
let's assume
um so the so we got sunlight we gotta
don't do it we don't somehow we got to
retreated ejaculation we've got sunlight
exercise Stress Control through
physiological double inhale long exhale
through the mouth
um try and be a nose breather and not a
mouth breather
um listen I also think it's a really
good idea in addition to seeking good
social connection Etc I think it's good
to have some practice that makes you
more resilient and I'm a big fan of cold
showers and I ice baths and cold they
have great banyas here in New York and
um you know put yourself into
uncomfortable cold three or five days a
week it's not about the metabolism
increase as much as is the mental
training of doing something that sucks I
mean David Goggins has this right and
actually this brings us back to this the
the importance of Story I mean David is
a guy who just keeps pushing himself and
pushing himself to do the hard thing but
I think the reason he's so effective as
a communicator is because we understand
that he had to go through a journey that
was incredible from being this 300 plus
pound guy to that and he's still doing
it so we're like in his story he's still
going and so I think all of us would do
well to
yeah to push ourselves to be
uncomfortable and then with the cold
what's beautiful is after you get out of
the cold and I like to end on warm
shower you do a minute or three minutes
of a cold or getting the ice bath or
whatever it is you get this huge
long-lasting surge in dopamine that sets
your mood and your positivity for hours
and hours this has been shown by data
and so I think it's a wonderful tool and
it's listen these are basically zero
cost tools they take time I wish I had
developed these tools in my 20s yeah I
built them gradually I've been working
out a long time and little things here
and there but if you start them early
they stay with you and I always think
the best way to outperform everybody in
your business or at least keep up in
very competitive business
and Joe Rogan is a beautiful example of
this is to take excellent care of your
health yeah he's I mean think about
three or four or four hour podcasts a
week plus the comedy thing but it's a
superhuman plus UFC you're doing this
like people who are really good at their
craft invest in taking really good care
of themselves and then of course that
includes avoid toxic relationships just
avoid them they ruin people's lives
they'll ruin your life like just do your
best to be in healthy relationships and
then everything's good and I don't say
that lightly like that's a big one I've
seen so many people who were doing great
but because they got caught up in some
drama they just nosedive the whole thing
so those are those would be the
recommendations there are a bunch of
others and I'll keep spouting them out
on the internet doctor
just saved your life okay you could do
all that stuff or you could just go get
peptides like the rest of us yo this
clip was brought to you by rocket money
formerly true bill to save more and
spend less join the 3.4 million members
using rocket money at rocketmoney.com
flagrant to get started for free that's
rocketmoney.com flagrant to get started
for free